OUR NEXT GAME.
MARRY KATE
IT'S TIME FOR MARRY KATE.
FORMER CHILD STAR AND FUTURE SEA
WITCH MARY-KATE OLSEN
--JUST OFFICIALLY TIED THE KNOT
TO OLIVIER SARKOZY, A FRENCH
BANKER WHO LOOKS LIKE HE SHOULD
BE FIGHTING STEVEN SEAGAL ON AN
OIL PLATFORM.
>> SHE LOOKS SUPER HAPPY.
>> SO HAPPY.
Chris: HE ALSO LOOKS LIKE A
HUMAN BEING.
>> IS HIS HEAD UPSIDE DOWN?
Chris: HE'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS AS A KID YOU GET THE
SHAVINGS AND THE MAGNET.
HE'S VERY HAPPY NOW.
[ APPLAUSE ]
NOW, SOME HAVE TAKEN ISSUE WITH
THE AGE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
29-YEAR-OLD SICK BIRD AND HER
46-YEAR-OLD BEAU, BUT WHAT'S
REALLY GOT PEOPLE TALKING IS THE
REPORT THAT THEIR WEDDING DECOR
INCLUDED "BOWLS AND BOWLS FILLED
WITH CIGARETTES."
THEY'RE SHOCKED THERE WERE
CIGARETTES AT A FRENCH WEDDING?
I THINK THEY HAVE THEM AT FRENCH
PRESCHOOLS.
BUT I THINK WEDDING FAVORS DO
SAY A LOT ABOUT A COUPLE SO
I WANT TO SHOW YOU A PICTURE OF
A CELEBRITY COUPLE.
TELL ME WHAT A GUEST RECEIVES AT
THEIR WEDDING.
FIRST UP BRANGELINA.
A BOWL OF
SOMALI BABIES.
>> Chris: NEXT UP.
JAY-Z AND BEYONCE.
>> JAY-Z'S SELF HELP BOOK
TURNING YOU
FROM A JIGGA WHAT TO A JIGGA WHO
Chris: NEXT UP.
BERT AND EARNY .
>> BOWLS OF CIGARETTES.
Chris: POINTS.
NEXT UP, JOHN TRAVOLTA AND KELLY
PRESTON.
>> A SCIENTOLOGY JOKE I'M NOT
GOING TO MAKE HERE, CHRIS.
>> Chris: ARE YOU --
WORRIED THE
SCIENTOLOGISTS THAT RUN A LOT
OF HOLLYWOOD --
>> NO I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT
SCIENTOLOGISTS AT ALL.
>> I'M NOT WORRIED.
Chris: WHAT ABOUT YOU, ADAM?
>> NO, I'M FINE WITH THEM.
ARE THEY HERE?
>> Chris: THEY'RE EVERYWHERE.
NEXT UP KIM AND KANYE.
ADAM.
>> IF YOU'RE A BLACK DUDE YOU
GET A KARDASHIAN.
IF YOU'RE A KARDASHIAN YOU GET A
BLACK DUDE.
>> Chris: POINTS.